hi i'm william zabka hi i'm ralph
macchio hi i'm peyton list i'm jacob
scott thomas bertrand i'm gianni dicenzo
i'm solomon yeah and i am mary mauser
and we are here with buzzfeed to take a
quiz to figure out which cobra kai
character we actually are
what quality do you most admire in a
friend loyalty sense of humor empathy
creativity sense of adventure or
confidence see this one is really hard
because i want to pick two oh that's
very
miyagido eagle fang of you no it's very
i'm going to say a sense of adventure
you want to be friends with boring
people let's say a sense of humor oh no
watch me get talk
sorry i put sense of adventure i did too
uh i put sense of humor i like funny
people so i hate all of you
oh it's you sick burn bro so what are
you thinking sense of humor i mean i
don't care about loyalty
i want someone who makes me laugh and uh
keeps me entertained no i'm just kidding
it's gonna be loyalty he's lying okay he
was going sense of humor and he's like
maybe that's a hero i'd be that would be
a question he's being influenced we need
to be in soundproof boots right choose
an 80s song to belt out at karaoke
another one bites a dust by queen super
trooper by abba
never gonna give you up by rick astley
take on me by aha total eclipse of the
heart by bonnie tyler or i want to dance
with somebody by whitney houston whitney
houston that song is awesome for old
time's sake though i have to pick super
trooper i know i'm doing take on me
music video slaps
i think i might have to do never going
to give you up because i think that
should be our future song we're going to
get it
they're like please don't actually do
yeah it's copyright like i stopped what
are you picking me yeah i want to dance
with somebody
yeah that's just a hard one vocally it
feels so much fun never gonna give you
up by rick ashley i know that's yours
i'm gonna go take on me by aha i mean i
could never hit those notes but that's
exactly why i would sing it
i'm going another one bites the dust of
course i mean that's the one that you do
no but it's just because i know loyalty
and another one bites the dust it's
going to be confused but
when another one bites the dust comes on
everybody knows it and stuff if somebody
hears aha kid gone they're gonna be
zooming in to see who's gonna attempt to
sing those notes no but i see you in the
convertible on uh pch going never gonna
give you
i just see it do any of you guys have
singing on your resumes i've i've
mastered lego builder i respect that
yeah okay now pick a cobra kai character
to fight alongside amanda larusso john
crease allie mills terry silver chosen
taguchi kim day in chosen yeah
absolutely chosen yeah he's so badass
yes i'm going to choose terry silver
because money definitely not
everything's about money gianni he's so
rich he's like he can buy artillery i
chose chosen he's got such cool weapons
um chosen all right what did you choose
chosen okay i'm going tradition i'm
staying i'm going chosen to gucci all
right i'm going with amanda there you go
choose a high school class to attend we
have lego robotics taylor swift and the
sociology of fame uh how to watch
television 101 vampires in cinema street
fighting and physics history of karate
street fighting in physics sounds
awesome i am so torn between taylor
swift and vampires and cinema the lego
robotics sounds pretty cool
that's you i'm between lego robotics and
street fighting yeah the street fighting
oh yes the tune that goes hand in hand
when you're a cool nerd like me they do
i just don't know which ones
all right i said vampires in cinema i
chose lego robotics oh i'm gonna build a
robot to kill everyone this is a tough
one for whatever reason okay i'm gonna
pretend these are actual clowns i'm
curious to to see what how to watch
television 101 would be maybe there's
something i'm missing
i'm gonna choose the same one that's the
one i would pick choose an iconic 80s
movie to reboot the goonies fast times
at ridgemont high ferris bueller's day
off back to the future beetlejuice or
dirty dancing this is so it's like so
hard yeah but at the same time i don't
want to reboot it anymore
are you sure that you want to say that
well they're not doing a reboot
mary's alluding the fact that i love
ferris bueller's day off but i wouldn't
want to do a reboot of it because it's
it's it shouldn't attack it shouldn't be
touched but the clutch
uber kai creators are doing a story
about the valet drivers and that's gonna
be genius yeah i'm gonna choose i think
fast time i'm gonna go with fast i think
beetlejuice what's the guy who did
nightmare before christmas tim burton
tim burton i think if tim burton did
didn't he do modern
oh he did the original
juice's whole personality is being
so creepy toward women okay i feel like
you can't get away with that hopefully
no one's trying to get away with that in
2022. beetlejuice is a woman actually
winona ryder plays beetlejuice
oh i picked dirty dancing oh i picked
back to the future because i have a
friend that loves back to the future so
i would rub it in his face if i could be
in it
i'm picking fast times yeah i was gonna
say fast times as well i just don't know
you'd probably have to change some stuff
it's a different time now pick an actor
from another netflix project to star in
a movie with kristen bell reggae jean
paige winona writer kevin hart lana
condor and paul rudd
i'm yeah paul rudd we're birthday twins
it's reggae
it's rigged on page don't even
work with kristen bell she's funny she
is really funny yes paul ryan i'm just
going with rudd i'm just going with fred
he has no wrong answer there kevin hart
would be fun too yeah kevin would be
great i'm gonna go with paul too no
offense to everybody else but uh i knew
paul back when way in the day so i'm
gonna go with paul and maybe get some
time to catch up choose something
important from cobra kai mr miyagi's
medal of honor the all valley karate
tournament terry silver's cobra kai
eli's hawk tattoo larusso auto group
johnny's coors
yeah i'm gonna go fastball down the
middle probably what everybody would
expect but you're taking the medal of
honor got to take the medal of honor if
you get a medal of honor well guess what
i'm going johnny's queer banquet then
i'm gonna have to offset that i mean
what's more important to cover kai than
the tattoo i picked medal of honor i
went with coors banquet yeah i i like my
own character's tap but coors is just
way cooler i'm going to choose the all
valley karate tournament yeah same old
valley
i'm sam larusso
you're yourself i'm me i am the
character i play wait a minute so what
look who larusso where did i go wrong
across the board first of all i'm just
excited that my character description is
correct kind smart and the tiniest bit
competitive like daniel you hate
breaking the rules and always strive to
do what's right you do anything for the
people you love although sometimes you
may lose sight of what's important
you're strong determined and extremely
generous you always put your heart and
soul into everything you do boom wow you
know what though this is actually very
true
i mean you're brave intelligent total
sweetheart
people sometimes mistake your kindness
as weakness but you never fail to show
people just how powerful you really are
like sam you're loyal determined and
ambitious you always try to do the right
thing and care a lot about people you
love people admire you and love having
you as a friend i can't believe that
you're actually dead you're you're like
ralph machu actually is daniel russo
he's just a little bit more competitive
than me it says retake can i retake it
and see if i get another result i'm
doing it really quick no no no go i'm
doing sense of humor another one bites
the dust i'm fighting along with classic
johnny law come on i'm fighting along
with chris he says i'm doing like
vampires
just kidding
the truth uh i'm freaking you now
yeah three
two
one
sam miguel
[Laughter]
you look so sad oh yeah what does it say
at least it says ultimate symptom it
says your impulsive tough and a natural
born leader at first people think they
know exactly who you are but you're
always full of surprises you have a big
heart and a lot of love to give though
sometimes your ambition gets in the way
of that you always have the best
intentions even though your methods of
achieving that might not be the best oh
true people really love you and your
dedication that's very gemini johnny
lawrence you're strong competitive and
determined like johnny you never back
down from a fight that's true oh god
some people may underestimate you at
first that's also true but you always
prove yourself to be much fierce than
anyone ever imagined you don't like to
change and you're a little bit stubborn
i wouldn't say that however you
eventually learn to embrace newness and
open your heart to the people who love
you now we know we're going to recast
the whole i'm really curious what it
says for like the tory bio it's like you
are a little deranged
get help
i recommend therapy
pretty fun that was fun that was fun bye
buzzfeed bye bye
thank you and be sure to check out cobra
kai on netflix
[Music]
you